how are you doing I'm great so one of
the things that I learned today that I
get to ask you is that you're on osoka
yeah and we now we get to talk about
that okay so what was like what was it
like finding out that they wanted you
know your character to be part of the
series
it was a real treat and a big surprise
and I love that um
she's such a valuable part of the story
I love that obviously I'm quite
passionate about her because I play her
but it was wonderful to be asked to step
in and just play for a moment
the other thing is that indoor is not
using the volume and Ahsoka uses the
volume so what was that like for you
that was extraordinary for me because
I've never experienced anything like
that before
um I one of the things I love about
Andor and I'm quite passionate about is
how much is filmed in Canberra that all
those sets that we walk on that you can
touch them that you can feel them that
they feel that they're a part of the
fabric of the piece and they're part of
the fabric of our performances as well
because they're so tactile they're
wonderful
um going on to being able to have the
opportunity to go on to the volume was
really different and it was amazing to
be able to work with different
filmmakers with different Crews and how
they work in a very different way it it
it's a it's a different style it's um
I feel very fortunate that I have been
had the opportunity to step into those
different worlds so my last thing for
you or maybe it's not who knows so now
let's talk about indoor season two yeah
we saw that footage looks fantastic
which is not a surprise uh we see uh
what looks like more missions more
everything so where do we find you in in
season two what can you tease about
season two well I think what Tony does
did brilliantly and what everybody
really strived for in season one is to
set up that whole world you know each of
the characters intimately by the end you
know what they what their ideals are you
know what they are passionate about you
know what their uh what the what their
own personal sacrifice is it really
investigates sacrifice in the weight in
the with the wall of Oppression how what
is
Collective sacrifice and what is a
personal sacrifice
and Monmouth we learned in and or so
beautifully is that manmatma's Monmouth
meets the Empire not just at work not
just within the Imperial Center but also
at home yeah and so what does she have
to sacrifice in order
to feel or to continue or to support
um Rebellion against
oppression and I was going to say is
there any chance of a divorce
I mean you have to see um you have to
see how it evolves I think what we do
know is that in in Rogue one she's in
Java so we know there's a ways to go in
season two and we're right in the middle
of it
I'm so excited I I can't wait for you to
see it listen Tony basically told me uh
like yavin's coming he said to me it's
like things you know have to happen are
coming on season two you know it's
happening and it's it's it's it's
grittier it's more passionate it's more
dangerous it's more emotional like the
emotional weight of season two is quite
a thing I'm so excited for you to see it
on that note I was going to say congrats
and I really can't wait until next year